I am so excited for you with this movie
this is a really big question to start
with here but because you've now worked
with four directors on this character
that I really admire can you pinpoint
something about a lease that you can
attribute to working with each of them a
new layer to her that they each helped
you bring out wow what a question
um
you know what not really because
gratefully
they pretty let me pretty much let me do
what I was finding the one note I ever
got from James Juan is that I was too
funny
there was one line it had to do in the
very first movie this is for real
because we know she's a very we never
really discussed it and I mean I've been
given notes you know in terms of you
know you want a little more of this or a
little more of that but that's that's
given it's pretty much on set for
whatever you're doing but they've been
very respectful and embrace of of
whatever I've brought into the franchise
and even in this last one I remember
um because Elise is often the deliverer
of information and
um I think that was what they fell in
love with and the first one that I had
this long two three pages of talking
about the further which nobody it was
setting up a universe that no one had
ever knew anything about and I filled it
though with um
emotion that there was some that each
thing I I and I that's my skill as an
actress I think and I'm you know great
for udahoga and Stella Adler and Lee
Strasberg were my three teachers and
don't ever do it unless you're feeling
it with something of yours and that's a
great comment for any actor out there
that's so much yeah it's never just
informational there's no such thing
unless you're really supposed to be a
newscaster and only delivering you know
whatever but so long story short
um there was a scene where uh specs he
had bumped his head it was in the first
one and he had some frozen peas and we
thought he should put the frozen peas on
his head at one point James said not
there you can't do it there because the
next line is not going to be funny you
know we need to we need to not have it
be funny there and actually I think Lee
uses those peas anyway when I wasn't
looking
but
um I've been very very very fortunate
that I've been my ideas have been
embraced as they should they know what
they had when they hired you for that
role and they ran with it thank you oh I
love how Elise kind of functions as as
like a ray of light she radiates warmth
in this dark scary franchise so I've two
questions about that first is there a
quality of elise's that you've taken
with you a source of inspiration that
you found yourself referring to in your
own life in the real world great
question
[Music]
um
perspective on some level uh
to consider both sides a little bit more
closely I mean she's a wonderful
listener
that I'm taking I hope to take with me I
don't think I've done the very good job
but
but inspired to be as good of a listener
as Elise you're listening to my
questions so I feel like
I just cut you off yeah
the second half to uh to that idea do
you have a favorite a least like movie
character from another film a character
who does function as a ray of light and
UPS The Hope in another really dark film
out there no
I can't think of what oh I'll throw out
the one that came to my mind because I
love the scream franchise it's Deputy
Dewey scary stuff happens but he is
always looking out for everybody and
shines through as that sense of hope
okay that was my answer then
have answered yourself because that's
what you do in this movie
congratulations on the red door and the
entire franchise fantastic great
questions thank you so much you are
wonderful